[Música]
y en directo vamos a Florida en Estados
Unidos para hablar con nuestro
corresponsal alto nivelci sobre el
juicio por difamación contra el locutor
estadounidense Alex Jones quien durante
años deslegítimo la masacre en la
escuela Sandy Hook en 2012 y dijo que el
tiroteo fue una escenificación y que
además hacía parte de un complot del
gobierno para quitarles las armas a los
estadounidenses como consecuencia de
estas mentiras las familias de las
víctimas sufrieron amenazas de muerte y
hostigamientos y ahora Jones debe
pagarles 965 millones de dólares Antonio
muy buenas noches háblenos de esta
indemnización y además como reaccionaron
las familias de las víctimas y la
defensa del sujeto
Hola qué tal Muy buenas noches Andrés
por sí efectivamente la justicia de
Estados Unidos ha condenado a pagar con
casi mil millones de dólares a 8 de las
familias de las víctimas de este tiroteo
de san de juki también a una gente del
FBI por efectivamente por un caso de
difamación en una corte de Connecticut
todo empezó hace unos años cuando este
hombre muy famoso aquí en Estados Unidos
a través de su plataforma de podcast
empezó a decir que todo se trataba de
una farsa lo que provocó un gran
malestar entre las familias que llevaron
este caso ante la justicia a partir de
ese momento el mismo Alex Jones se
retrató y dijo que efectivamente ese
tiroteo era real pero ya era demasiado
tarde ya que muchísimos seguidores de
este hombre empezaron a acosar a algunos
de los padres hay que recordar que este
caso el tiroteo de Sandy Hook causó una
gran conmoción aquí en Estados Unidos El
principalmente porque un joven armado de
20 años Adam lanza entró en esa escuela
matando a 20 niños y seis adultos ahora
se ha resuelto ese segundo caso ante la
justicia y algunos de esos padres
celebraban esta esta decisión de la
justicia de Estados Unidos Aunque muchos
de ellos lamentaban de que pues
obviamente los las vidas de sus hijos no
la van a poder recuperar jamás Antonio Y
es que en agosto a Alex Jones también la
habían ordenado a pagar otros 49
millones de dólares a otras familias de
una víctima porque
Sí precisamente este son tres casos el
primer caso se
resolvió en agosto efectivamente cuando
se tuvo que indemnizar con 50 millones
de dólares a los padres de Jessy Lewis
un niño de 6 años pero ahora falta otro
caso que se va a resolver en una corte
de Texas son los padres de no a poder
que por cierto esos mensajes fueron los
primeros en interponer una demanda
contra Alex Jones y también los que
pidieron a las principales plataformas
de redes sociales que eliminarán
cualquier tipo de contenido relacionado
con este podcast Aparentemente este
tercer caso se va a resolver
satisfactoriamente viendo estos dos
últimos casos que se han tratado en la
corte de Estados Unidos pero también
porque hay que tener en cuenta de que ya
una corte obligó a pagar con un millón
de dólares a la familia de este de Este
joven